june is going to be a huge month in
american politics because we're going to
hear about the january six select
hearings the public hearings you know
that we are going to stream them here on
the tony michael's podcast every single
one of them gavel to gavel but also in
the month of june we're expected to
receive the late decision from the
supreme court so this morning we find
out that the supreme court is requesting
the law clerks hand over their text
messages this is all distraction this is
distraction from the actual text
messages that we're going to see in
these public hearings from an actual
wife of a supreme court justice who was
trying to overturn the united states
government who was trying to commit a
coup that's right i said it jeannie
thomas and clarence thomas these q and
honors have infiltrated the supreme
court and it needs to be investigated if
we can investigate a stupid [ __ ] leak
of a decision that they're going to make
to take away our rights we absolutely
absolutely can investigate and should
investigate the coup attempt that
happened by the supreme court justice's
wife she was text messaging the chief of
staff all kinds of crazy ass q and on
stuff we should not forget about this
and we should not believe or or [ __ ]
pay attention much to the distraction of
the leak i i would imagine that we're
gonna find out that this leak
investigation is not gonna lead down the
road that they want and the media is
buying all this [ __ ] distraction this
watch this hand while we do this other
thing watch this hand over here while we
commit a coup over here that's what it
is distraction they're gonna distract us
with the leak of a decision that they're
going to make think about this for a
second we're supposed to believe that
the high crime that has been committed
in the supreme court is that the
decision that they're going to make to
take away women's rights and liberties
of their body that they have
constitutionally in this country right
now that that is the high crime that was
committed in the supreme court give me a
[ __ ] break forget about
buying and paying for the justices the
right-wing coots that are on the supreme
court forget about that that [ __ ]
crime in the first place how they bought
and paid for it through the federalist
society of making sure that minority
ideology rules in this country forget
about that for a second forget about how
we can't have 13 justices we have to
have nine which makes no sense we have
13 districts we should have 13 justices
that's the framing of the supreme court
it only makes common sense logic it's
not [ __ ] rocket science but forget
about that that part of it we're
supposed to believe that the high crime
that was committed in the supreme court
is someone leaked the decision that
they're gonna make this month we're not
supposed to believe that the wife of
supreme court justice who was texting
the chief of staff while the coup is
happening while the coup is ongoing
while donald trump tried to take over
our government rip up the constitution
and [ __ ] on it throw it in the toilet
and flush it i guess i don't know it
seems to be a trend but that's what
we're supposed to believe get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] and this
morning when this report comes out about
these staffers or some [ __ ] about text
messages we should be on a crusade folks
this morning yelling and screaming at
the top of our lungs continually and we
shouldn't stop again we're one issue
voters now we have to be one-issue
voters because it is clear now more than
ever what their mission is their mission
is to take away our [ __ ] democracy
take away our right as a people to
decide how we can keep kids safe in a
school they want to take away our
[ __ ] right to do that they want to
take away our right as a people to make
sure that guns don't get into the wrong
hands and that maybe some of these guns
aren't manufactured in the first place
for pure profit they want to take away
our rights to our to our bodies women
don't even have the right to their
uterus in some states anymore to medical
decisions that are made between them and
their doctor about their life and we're
supposed to believe this morning that
the big huge controversy
at the big huge crime committed in this
country was a leak of a decision that
they're going to make it's not like
they're claiming oh my god this person
is lying who cares who leaked it is
probably a right winger in the first
place who gives a [ __ ] that's probably
what we're gonna find out in the long
run this investigation and no
investigation ever works out well for
these right-wingers we've seen that i
mean remember how important a certain
email ladies emails were several years
ago remember how important hunter
biden's laptop is to the biden
presidency remember that
give me a [ __ ] break these
investigations never [ __ ] pan out for
these morons and the reason why is
because they're always based in delusion
they spew [ __ ] out all their holes and
it will continue that way this morning
they're mad that these law clerks have
text messages get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ] and the mainstream media
is buying this [ __ ] hook line sinker
hook line sinker don't buy it make the
noise of the real [ __ ] crimes that
are being committed in the supreme court
jeannie thomas the wife of clarence
thomas that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] was
texting the chief of staff who was
standing next to the person who was
trying to overthrow our government and
encouraging it not only encouraging
giving them ideas on how to overthrow
our constitution and then and then
clarence thomas got to make decisions on
the evidence without recusing himself
you want to talk about [ __ ] crimes
they can't stop crimin they can't stop
criming we can't take our eye off the
prize here folks the prize is our
democracy it is at stake every [ __ ]
waking moment we have to fight for it
everywhere because these fascists are
not going to stop